you know when you just get cornered with
somebody who just like won't shut the
[__] up Nia you know what that's like
right
every day oh every day it's so difficult
living with old Billy back brace um when
um you know somebody won't shut the [__]
up and you're not giving them anything
and the person will literally talk to
the side of your face for 40 straight
minutes they just won't get it they just
don't get the hint that you as a human
being have disengaged from whatever life
experience that has created them to do
what they're doing to you right then
right if that isn't working if they can
literally sit there and talk to the side
of your [__] face like you're a horse
and they're brushing your back
at that point you gotta go with an
excuse you can't go with I threw out my
back that only works over the phone and
via text I would say you got to go with
I got kids I got a dog you know what my
buddy of mine used the other day I gotta
take a piss